34 % c'est le pourcentage des 18 24 ans
qui ont donné leurs voix au candidat de
la france insoumise à quelques jours du
second tour nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre pour savoir ce qu'ils comptent
faire vu pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'important j'irai voter mais je pense
blanc parce qu'il ya aucun des deux
candidats qui m'intéressent second tour
c'est vrai que j'ai hésité à aller voter
ou pas parce que du coup c'est les
candidats qui sont sortants sais pas
pourquoi j'ai voté mais je pense que
je pense que je voterai pour macron pour
commencer par et l'extrême droite et
mais j'ai quand même peur parce que je
pense que c'est encore un mont pilate
une mauvaise surprise cette année a
priori je pense que je vais m'abstenir
parce que je suis ni en faveur de marine
le pen ou de emmanuel macron donc pour
pas jouer le jeu des barrages pense que
je vais m'abstenir je compte n'est pas
donné de voir l'extrême droite et faire
blocus et est votée mâcon face à la
hausse du score du rassemblement
national mais aussi des voix attribué à
eric zemmour les jeunes se montrent
plutôt inquiets bon je suis personne
noire et c'est vrai que quand on regarde
même zemmour qui a quand même 7 % des
voix s'est tendue quand même
donc oui ça me fait peur déjà avec
zemmour qui est dé diaboliser un peu
marine le pen et on a un peu oublié
vraiment l'essentiel autour de sa
personne même si c'est vrai qu'elle
donne une image un peu plus ouverte mais
c'est quand même c'est le sait les rites
âge de son papa donc faut pas faut pas
se leurrer sur certains sur certains
points notamment tout ce qui est de nos
phobies choqué que marine le pen en fait
les gens ils ont oublié que c'était
l'extrême droite et c'est vrai que ça me
choque ac après on s'en doutait qu'elle
allait passer au second tour c'est quand
même signe d'une montée du extrémisation
au racisme à l'anti migration etc donc
oui forcément ça me fait peur pour
l'avenir partout en france les étudiants
élèvent leur voix et bloque les
universités ils ne veulent pas choisir
une nouvelle fois entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen